we now follow a program that parallels
our development for the case of the
Bernoulli process we will study the time
until the first arrival a random
variable that we denote by t1 we are
interested in finding the probability
distribution of this random variable and
later on we will continue and try to
study the time until the case arrival
now T 1 is a continuous random variable
because the Poisson process runs in
continuous time and therefore it has a
PDF but instead of finding the PDF
directly we will first find the cdf of
this random variable so we fix a certain
time T and we're asking for the
probability that the first arrival
happens during this interval now this is
1 minus the probability that the first
arrival happens outside this interval so
we can write this probability as 1 minus
the probability that t1 is bigger than T
but what is this event the first arrival
occurring after time little T is the
same as saying that there were no
arrivals in the time interval from 0 to
little T and this probability of zero
arrivals in a time interval of length T
is something for which we already have a
formula take this formula and replace K
by 0 tau by T when K is equal to 0 this
term is something to the zeroth power
equal to 1 using our convention that 0
factorial is equal to 1 we're left just
with e to the minus lambda T and this is
the answer for the CDF of the time until
the first arrival we then take a
derivative and we find that the PDF of
the time until the first arrival has
this form which is the PDF of an
exponential random variable of course
this calculation here is only valid for
T's that are non negative for negative
T's the PDF of T 1 is of course 0 for
the exponential random variable we have
seen that it has certain memory less
properties namely if I condition on the
event that nothing has occurred until at
certain time T and I'm interested in the
time from now until the first arrival
occurs this remaining time until the
first arrival is again an exponential
distribution that is looking ahead from
this time I will still wait and
exponentially distributed the amount of
time until I see the first arrival
whatever happened in the past and how
long I have been waiting doesn't matter
starting from this time I will still
wait and exponentially distributed
amount of time this is essentially an
expression of a fresh start property of
the Poisson process which is analogous
to the fresh start properties for the
Bernoulli process and we will be
discussing this fresh start property a
lot more having figured out the
distribution of the time of the first
arrival let us now study the time of the
caithe arrival a random variable that we
denote by y sub k similar to the case of
the Bernoulli process this random
variable is a continuous one because
arrivals happen in continuous time so it
takes continuous values and therefore it
will be described by a PDF and this is
what we want to find in order to find it
we will make use of the Poisson PMF that
we have already derived for the number
of arrivals during an interval of a
fixed length one approach to finding the
PDF of YJ is the usual program similar
again to what we did for the case of the
first arrival time we can first find the
CDF and then differentiate to find the
PDF so what is the CDF we want to
calculate the probability that y K is
less than or equal to some number little
Y now what is this event the caithe
arrival occurs by time Y this means that
by time Y we've had at least K arrivals
we've had J arrivals or maybe K plus 1
or maybe k plus 2 we've had some number
of
rivals and in an interval of length why
and this is an event that happens with
this probability but we need to take
into account all the possible values of
n that are at least as large as K now we
have a formula for this probability the
probability of n arrivals in an interval
of given length this is the Poisson PMF
with appropriate changes of symbols so
we can take this expression substitute
it here and then differentiate do some
algebra and find the answer instead of
carrying out this algebra
however we will proceed in a more
intuitive way that will get us there
perhaps faster and the derivation that
we will follow actually parallels the
one that we went through in the case of
the Bernoulli process the intuitive
argument that we will use will rest on
the interpretation of a PDF in terms of
probabilities of small intervals so the
PDF evaluated at some particular point Y
times Delta is approximately the
probability that our random variable
falls within a delta interval from this
number little Y that we are considering
so here x 0 here's time Y and here's
time y plus Delta we want to find or to
say something about the probability of
falling inside this small interval now
what does it mean
for the case arrival to fall inside this
interval this is an event that can
happen as follows the case arrival Falls
in this interval and we have K minus 1
arrivals during the previous interval
what is the probability of this event a
basic assumption about the Poisson
process is the independence assumption
therefore having K minus 1 arrivals in
this interval and having one arrival in
this interval are independent events
therefore the probability of this
scenario is the product of the
probabilities that
had K minus 1 arrivals in an interval of
length y times the probability that
we've had one arrival in an interval of
length Delta and that latter probability
is approximately equal to lambda times
Delta so I should write here an
approximate equality instead of an exact
equality to indicate that there are
other terms order of Delta square for
example but which are much smaller
compared to Delta however this is not
the only way that we can get the case
arrival in this interval there's an
alternative scenario we might have had K
minus 2 arrivals during this interval
and then two arrivals during that little
interval in this case the K arrival
again occurs within that little interval
so we need to also calculate the
probability of this scenario the
probability of that scenario is the
probability of K minus 2 arrivals in an
interval of length y times the
probability of two arrivals but the
probability of two arrivals is something
that's order of Delta squared and order
of Delta squared is much smaller than
this term which is linear in Delta and
so this term can be ignored as long as
we're just keeping track of the dominant
terms those that are linear in Delta and
then they would be similar expressions
for example the scenario that we have
three arrivals up to time Y and then
three more arrivals during that little
interval which is again an event of
probability order of Delta square that
we get three arrivals there and all of
those terms are insignificant and we can
ignore them and we end up with an
approximate equality between this term
and this expression here Delta shows up
on both sides so we can cancel Delta and
therefore we have ended up with a
formula for the PDF in particular the
PDF is equal to this probability times
lambda
what is this probably
we have a formula for it but we just
need to substitute put K minus 1 in the
place of K and put a Y in the place of
tau this gives us lambda Y to the power
K minus 1 e to the minus lambda Y
divided by K minus 1 factorial and then
we have the extra factor of lambda which
can be put together with this lambda to
the K minus 1 here and we end up with
this final formula for the PDF of YK the
distribution that we have here is called
an Erlang distribution but actually it's
not just one distribution we have
different distributions depending on
what K were considering the distribution
of the time of the third arrival is
different from the distribution of the
tenth arrival so if we fix a particular
k then we say that we have an earlier
distribution of order k for the case
where k is equal to 1 this term here
disappears k minus 1 is equal to 0 and
the denominator term disappears and we
end up with lambda times e to the minus
lambda Y but this is the exponential
distribution that we had already derived
with a different method earlier as you
increase K of course you get different
distributions and these tend to shift
towards the right this makes sense the
time of the second arrival is likely to
take certain values the time of the
third arrival is likely to take values
that are higher and the more you
increase K the more the distribution
will be shifting towards the right